all means same terminal means where it
terminates her stops so if you think
about you want to find an angle that
stops or terminates in the same place
that's 30 degrees 30 degrees is right
there if you add 360 degrees you're
gonna end up in the same spot if you
subtract 360 degrees you're gonna end up
in the same spot so what you can do is
just add 360 that's going to be 390
degrees
390 degrees or you can subtract 360 and
that's gonna give you a negative 330
degrees either way you're still going to
end up in the same spot on the unit
circle
same thing with radians if you take your
angle and you add 2 pi you're gonna be
going all the way around and you're
gonna have the same spot or if you
subtract 2 pi you're gonna be going this
direction you're gonna end up in the
same location so that's how you find
coterminal angles sometimes they'll give
you a problem like find one positive
coterminal angle and one negative
coterminal angle with 700 degrees you
may have to subtract 360 multiple times
until you get into an angle that's
negative so here we might have to
subtract 360 twice so that's negative
seven twenty so that would give you
negative twenty degrees okay if you add
360 that would give you a positive
coterminal angle that would be seven
hundred plus 360 which is a thousand 60
so by adding 360 subtracting 360 or
adding two pi or subtracting 2 pi you'll
end up in the same point on the unit
circle so this has been just an overview
of how to find coterminal angles I'll
see you in the next video